hello I'm clearly no Gallagher I am
responding to your internet questions
this is actually me first let's go to
the playground of the [ __ ] idiot
Twitter both Liam and Noel Gallagher's
bands always have at least two fellows
who look like Noel Gallagher is this a
contractual thing I'm afraid to say that
it is but you know at least we don't
have two girls you look like an old
Gallagher because that nobody wants to
see them tweeted I'm going to your
concert next year at London at London
are you going to play stuff off your
older solo albums
well almost certainly I'll be playing
them at London I'm probably at New York
as well and almost certainly does the
scissor player of a scissor East which
is not even a word in Noel Gallagher's
high flying bird to get a sound check or
better still does she have her own
scissor tech she is the scissor Queen
she can do anything
she does not get a sound check because
we have yet to do an actual gig she
doesn't have a scissor tech either
because scissor techs don't exist but no
doubt she'll want one and if she wants
one she can have one because she's
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
that's a good novel that's actually not
too dissimilar to our Liam sang it the
first time I played it I had to say to
him thank you enough the Carlotta [ __ ]
down man that's not gonna sell to
anybody in China I mean I got to say
I've [ __ ] heard worse I've heard
worse in rehearsals I mean it's not
great I don't know what he's got on his
head I think he's got to the essence of
the tune there it's pretty [ __ ] good
respect does anyone know why Knoll
Gallagher changes the key of our AC
songs during his solo shows when I was
in Oasis I would write a song in a
certain key and more often than not we
would have to bring that key down to
suit the other fellas voice so when I do
the Oasis songs in my own solo shows I
moved the key back up to where it was
originally intended there you go I've
been playing guitar for a few years now
and I've never really gone anywhere with
my son Ryan I would like to start
writing songs and have them in a similar
sound in vain to Oasis what sort of
chord progressions could I look at I've
had a play around with some of the
bluesy stuff and similar to all around
the world that Dixie dinner however I
don't seem to be going anywhere with it
I just wondered if anyone had any tips
for me well I'm gonna say if you think
all around the world and giggsy's dinner
are the [ __ ] blues then my tip for
you would to be pack it in and get
yourself a [ __ ] synthesizer posted
next up answers.com it's actually me
dozen old Gallagher believed in God I
believe in myself because I'm sat here
now so in a way I do but in another way
I don't submit who is richer no lore
Liam Gallagher I mean it really goes
without saying Quorra
who is the nicer brother Liam or Knoll
Gallagher and why well I mean it goes
without saying cuz I didn't try to sue
anybody that makes me nice I think enter
how did the Smiths guitarist Johnny Marr
inspire bands like Oasis and the Stone
Roses well I can't speak for the Stone
Roses I can only tell you that that man
has been an influence and an inspiration
to me since I first seen the Smiths in
1983 the guitars that I've played and
bought in my first years in Oasis
directly because Johnny Cueto he's an
all-around super [ __ ] dude he's a Man
City fan he is not cool I'm afraid
Yahoo Answers it's really me how do I
get the null Galaga Tom's the famous and
all Galaga Tom's for all you Isis fans
out there and for people who play guitar
what pedals in an app's do I need to
sound like an old Gallagher's Tom can
someone please tell me I've used the
Wikipedia it doesn't seem to help well
there's a [ __ ] surprise I use hiwatt
custom 50-ounce
currently nash jazzmasters currently the
effects pedals that I use are too
numerous to go into needless to say
you'd have to start with the amplifiers
but even then you'd need these and this
so good luck with that why doesn't all
Gallagher of Oasis called Liam our kid
it's a northern term that siblings used
to describe each other that's all I can
tell you that's all I know our kid enter
why did dave grohl spelt incorrectly
decide to leave Oasis I don't know what
that means dave grohl was never in Oasis
was he I mean I was [ __ ] out of my
life most of the time but was noticed I
don't think so he wishes his Noel
Gallagher actually God I mean most
people know but for some people yes but
as God doesn't actually exist and I'm
afraid I'm gonna have to do until
somebody better qualified comes along so
in a way yes Instagram what would these
hairstyles they were long if I remember
correctly we've just come back we've
been in the South of France recording an
album for about four months there was a
lack of hairdressers out in the South of
France and we were just letting it you
know grow free and easy man and quite
70s out like an insane picture let's go
to Wikipedia Gallagher spent
extravagantly buy various cars and a
swimming pool despite the fact that he
can neither drive nor swim he named his
house in Belsize Park in London
supernova Heights after the song
champagne supernova and his two cats
Benson & Hedges after his favorite brand
of cigarettes I'm afraid all this is
true I'm also afraid I was very high
during the 90s and drunk most of the
time I can only tell you that it was a
[ __ ] brilliant time in my life and I
was naming everything after everything
naming caps after cigarettes though one
of my finer moments I must say Gallagher
has said he sometimes does not
understand his own lyrics commented in
2005 but when I am halfway through
dollar buy
in anger I say to myself I still don't
know what these words mean there is a
bit of truth in that statement like the
bit in champagne supernova about slowly
walking down the hall faster than a
cannonball what does that mean and the
answer is I don't know what it means I
don't care what it means it must mean
something though because I play it to a
sea of people every night but they seem
to understand it that's all about as I
guess back to Quora who helps Noel
Gallagher write his songs since it's
been said he neither reads nor writes
music well I don't read nor like music
in the traditional sense like say
Beethoven I do it all myself
hence me being a genius did Noel
Gallagher write live forever after
having a dream in which he never died no
he did not
what that after having a dream in which
in every night is the makings of a good
lyric which I am going to steal off you
do it you are and I'm gonna put in a
song and buy myself another swimming
pool I am DB frequently uses a Gibson
es-335 P fallin Sheraton a guitar with a
uni jack finish which I don't use
anymore and only used it twice and a
Nash Jazz Master did liked ageing there
you go read it so as a headline from the
enemy that says non-catholic I've got a
soul drunk with Bono on tour that he
tried to escape the question is escape
what I'm not sure I was trying to escape
I wouldn't believe everything that's
written in the enemy anyway I can't
remember now because I was drunk does
anybody know where I could find these
sunglasses company called Garrett light
to believe they're American I don't know
where I got mine but I'm sure he can
find them on the Internet
but they are rather tasty Oasis snob the
Trainspotting soundtrack because Noel
Gallagher thought it was about real
train spas
I was at a party recently and I met
somebody from the production team of
transport and way back and they reminded
me that I did actually
especially that a film about trains bars
sounds [ __ ] boring and refused to
give them any music I have no
recollection of this but this woman did
insist that it did happen so seemingly
it would be true yes
funny story unfortunately we've come to
the end so this is me this is I know
Gallagher saying goodbye [ __ ] idiots